[Music]
you can't always
get what you want
you can't always get what you want
[Music]
you can't always get
[Music]
they understood that he was a bad guy
we got sick of it man we said that's it
enough's enough we're smashing the
machine
we rose up i felt like i went from
middle class to
the lower end we love you dearly trump
how un-american
i wouldn't want him to be my children's
sunday school teacher i would like him
to be my president
political correctness was the greatest
cancer in american public life
it hurt me it hurt my friends i've
shocked myself on how fast
i've went towards the right
i was more in shock than i could be in
fear
they have been emotionally gratified
by the smashing of the establishments of
both parties you've been through a
tunnel before
you know how dark it is but it's at the
end that's it that's why
that's what we're going through right
now
i've just received a call
from secretary clinton
[Applause]
she congratulated us it's about us
on our victory and i congratulated her
and her family on a very very hard ford
campaign
we must accept this result and then look
to the future
donald trump is going to be our
president
we are now all rooting for his success
and uniting
and leading the country
i pledge to every citizen of our land
that i will be president for all
americans
and this is so important to me
[Applause]
[Music]
but the problem with trump is that he
brings violence from both sides frankly
he brings out the worst in
everybody so um i'm concerned that we're
going to start to see a lot more
violence over the next coming months
i've spent the year watching a
polarizing election pull
families friends and neighbors apart
in the end the voice of the maverick
outsider won
out but it's still a hard pill for some
to swallow
americans had their say but many don't
feel their voices were heard after a
bitter election this is a nation
struggling to heal
i'm not ready to sit down and be quiet
and accept the results
i i really feel more than ever in my
lifetime
that our rights are at risk i'm not
willing to give him a chance
i'm i'm not trump
racist usa no trump no kkk
no racist usa no trump
no kkk oh all these kids that are
protesting
a lot of them didn't vote but but
they're out there protesting
what are you protesting oh i don't know
new fault lines are emerging and there's
fear in the air
the trump supporters will feel
emboldened and this
this area here could really stir our
country up
into a much more protest and civil war
if the trump supporters feel so
emboldened
that they start doing some really dumb
brazen things
they're going to find that they're not
the only one carrying guns
and they're going to find that it's
going to be really rough out here and
that's
that's a no-win situation for anybody
nobody wants that and i'm not
encouraging that in at least a little
bit but that's a reality
donald trump has vowed to unify the
nation but his
unorthodox campaign exposed some already
deep divisions
and his rhetoric has rocked the
political world
well donald trump is represents the sort
of existential threat to political
correctness which is the greatest
cancer in american public life
i love the old days you know what they
used to do to guys like that when they
were in a place like this
they'd be carried out on a stretcher
folks i see this guy oh i don't know
what i said ah
i don't remember i like to punch him in
the face i'll tell you
he's a war hero because he was captured
i like people that weren't captured okay
i hate to tell you
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime
they're rapists if i win they're going
back
they're going back i'm telling you
they're going back
build that wall build that wall build
that wall
build that wall build that wall
while i was with my friends and we were
sitting at lunch
it just like out of nowhere it just
started
slowly at first you hear people banging
on the tables
it gradually got louder
and then more people started to join in
saying build a wall build a wall
a day after trump was elected josie
recorded students
chanting a familiar slogan from his
rallies so she could show her mother
it went viral i was really angry
but i also felt sad and disappointed in
my
fellow students it hurt me it hurt my
friends who are also latino and
it hurt everybody it hurt
everybody and you shouldn't do that
that's wrong
what would you say to donald trump if
you could
what would i say to donald trump i just
don't under
i would say to him why would you say
this it was
it was so wrong of you to say this
you're a president and you're supposed
to respect
everybody in the country you
disrespected me and my culture i don't
understand why
42 years ago i suffered the same
injustices
not because i was not a us citizen
but because i didn't speak english
in our family we're taught spanish first
so
your first real experience with english
is in a school system
you know i you it was not uncommon that
you were locked in the closet or or
things of that nature so it was pretty
dramatic
but to see us here again and even at a
larger scale
is is
it leaves me speechless actually
it's unfortunate that it did repeat
itself and that my daughter has the same
struggle
42 years later how
un-american must that be 42 years later
she has the same struggle
they're harassing latinos muslims i am
so saddened to hear that and i say
stop it if it if it helps
i i will say this and i'll say it right
to the camera stop it
um just saying stop it i don't think is
enough
his response to the growing number of
incidents i think was inadequate
some muslim americans in dearborn are on
edge
in 2007 the islamic center of america
was vandalized
now in a different mosque they are
facing another testing time
i think you can do much more hopefully
in the next
few days in the coming weeks he will do
more than that and i think it's
incumbent upon him to
create an atmosphere of cooperation and
healing
and and to bring the country together
the president-elect who rallied against
the establishment
is busy building his inner circle
picking
steve bannon wants the driving force
behind the right-wing
breitbart news website as his chief
strategist
so breitbart news is a populist
libertarian conservative news outlet in
the u.s
i'm one of the senior editors there and
and we've been a fan of trump for a
little while
um we i think have have represented a
necessary counterbalance to
a lot of the name calling and
hectoring from the progressive left and
um
you know we're we've done a really good
job
and gratifyingly we're becoming one of
the you know the rising powers in the
american media landscape
it has become notorious for provocative
headlines condemned by
some as racist and misogynist steve
bannon has been described as a white
nationalist
but he firmly rejects the label
trump is not a very ideological person
trump has a sort of gut level
understanding of politics he's not a
theorist
steve bannon is a theorist and steve
bannon has a
theory of populist nationalism
that is not republican and is not
democrat and that's the ideology
he wants donald trump to embody as
president
he demands results but he's you know i
think bloomberg called him the most
dangerous political operative in america
um for good reason because the guy's
incredible um he's
uh he's compassionate and hard working
and very well connected
i think it's very much a preview of the
next four years i think
you know trump is going to put the
people he believes in
in his government his campaign was very
much
styled as a a
a war on political correctness i think
there's a lot of fear among liberals
that he believes that dissent is unfair
that criticism is unfair
and once he has the apparatus of the
state at his disposal
that could be a very frightening thing
he's made it so that it is no longer a
taboo subject to be a white nationalist
he's made it okay
he's going to be you know the top
adviser to the president united states
and
um with that he has an enormous amount
of power
which is already on top of the
significant sort of online power that he
has
through the white nationalist movement
[Applause]
steve bannon um is is
someone that we are very concerned about
as a muslim community
we are also concerned for some some of
the other things that he has said
that has attacked vulnerable populations
vulnerable citizens in our country
um we we will wait and see
hey
[Music]
big
[Music]
hours was not a campaign but rather an
incredible and great movement
made up of millions of hard-working men
and women
who love their country and want a better
brighter future for themselves
and for their family the forgotten men
and women
of our country will be forgotten no
[Applause]
longer
the voters who favored trump the most
strongly were the oldest voters
nostalgia was an overt theme of the
trump campaign if you think about his
slogan make america great
again it was a literal
assertion that this country used to be a
better place
than it is now quality in the things we
buy
is designed in built in and inspected in
from start to finish
the people that elected donald trump are
really
legitimate americans that have a real
legitimate
gripe about where this country's gone
when you see the areas that are red
red throughout all the states
representing the ones that voted for
donald trump
this country is straight up red now
because man
we rose up i knew i could feel it in my
gut i still can't
is that the guy that sits down at the
kitchen table every night with his
family looked around and said
what about me it's the forgotten man
that forgot man still out there
and we with grease under our fingernails
and i've got a lot of that too i've been
on those kind of jobs
we're the people that got forgotten they
took our jobs they took our
our they take our tax dollars they
finance all kinds of
largesse and welfare programs
in michigan a state that has
historically voted democrat
donald trump delivered a symbolic upset
in small towns and
rural communities i think the economy
drove
donald trump's vote a lot but
it's not it cannot be separated from the
problems with culture in this country
we have a very very deep um problem
you know between the races and between
regions
that combined with sort of economic
malaise in a lot of people's minds even
if the economy is doing much better than
it was eight years ago or ten years ago
they don't feel it they don't see it
they don't believe it um
they feel like even if it is doing
better it could evaporate down them at
any time
and so though that combined with this
sort of rapidly changing culture have
come together to really create
a very toxic environment in the middle
of the country
all those people standing behind donald
trump all those rallies
i saw that as man this is the sleeping
giant that they don't have a clue
and we just knew that we were rising up
this revolution man
this was a serious revolution in
american terms at the ballot box
and all those people behind donald trump
are the people that put mufflers on cars
they lifts on houses
do tax returns for people that work for
a living and said screw this i'm tired
of it
nick is a union member who used to vote
democrat
but his experience working in a factory
turned him towards trump
you know the auto industry was hit
really hard and in southeastern michigan
the auto industry is is you know the
major employer
and so there was massive cutbacks
10 years ago
they were sold they sold it to a french
company that
you know came in and the wages are
probably half what they were
and you know i was quite liberal for for
many many years and it's just in the
last few years
that i've found and i've shocked myself
on how fast i've
went towards the right i really i really
have surprised myself
economic anxiety and concern about
immigration
drove him to desert the party he felt no
longer represented him
i don't recognize the democratic party
anymore
i really don't
[Music]
they have went in ways that
i guess i don't agree with uh
the you know the the political
correctness i think is
is been taken to extremes
uh you know people are getting called
being called racists for just
disagreeing with someone
and i find that troubling
obama has reduced unemployment
significantly don't you think the
democrats can be credited with that
progress the jobs that he's created
are not high paying jobs there's
there's a big difference they're not
high paying jobs
he's he's brought in yeah a lot of
service sector jobs
but not manufacturing jobs those jobs
have have left what if he doesn't
deliver
we'll have to wait four years to get rid
of him
but uh i i think that i don't think that
he's going to be able to deliver
everything that he says he is but
uh i think that he's he's going to be
moving the country in a different
direction
one that you know working class
people like myself would like to see
for some this race was about
establishing your identity and security
even if that was at the expense of
others
they understood that he was a bad guy
he's frankly stoking the fires of a
you know very dangerous sort of race war
potentially in this country they
understand this
and they don't care they decided that
they think he's going to stand up to the
people that have been in charge
in this country for 40 years you know
corporate interests
you know entrenched politicians those
kind of people and they want them to
feel
pain and if that means that black people
have to feel pain or muslims have to
feel pain
or latinos have to feel pain or even if
their wife has to feel pain
they don't care
this was not racist by any stretch of
the imagination that's the picture
painted that's a hundred percent
lie this was every color shape and
stripe in america saying enough's enough
i want to be able to
keep my own money i want to spend it the
way i want it and i have no problem with
paying taxes to pay for responsible
things
but quit stealing from me and taking my
jobs to china
[Music]
i felt like i went from middle class to
the lower end
i really over the last 15 20 years
[Music]
and then i see the billions and billions
of dollars going
out of here and the money i pay on taxes
it's just not right and hopefully he's
gonna change that
people feel they're under threat they
want to feel
change the very thing many voted for
eight years ago
i vote for obama the first time why
because he he he says something about
change
the change that he brought to this
country is worse than what it was
when he first took office
before obama took office my son's been a
cop that long longer
i never worried about him and now you've
got all these black lives matter
that are putting targets on police
officers
and the obama administration is okay
with it and hillary
hillary wants to do the same thing he
did
sorry i'm choking up a little bit but
you know
on election night hillary clinton's
campaign was
gearing up for an historic victory but
she
failed to woo enough women voters
leaving her supporters in a state of
despair
women are mostly concerned to have a
fair workplace
a place uh fair child care affordable
health care
opportunities for themselves and their
husbands and these were the
conversations that we had
about donald trump's policies and
i think that women were also very very
interested
in trust and wanting to know that they
could trust
their president and while mr trump like
i said is not always very eloquent
i wouldn't want him to be my children's
sunday school teacher
but you'd like him to be your president
i would like him to be my president
for some significant group of the people
who voted for trump
simply having elected him is achievement
enough
they have been emotionally gratified
by the smashing of the establishments of
both parties
that pure expression of their anger and
frustration
that culminated in putting him in office
it almost doesn't matter what he does
just the fact that
they got that has already made their
lives significantly better
[Music]
donald trump is a political brawler who
had his finger
on the pulse
stop the feet
[Music]
come on
in detroit a bruising presidential
battle
still feels very fresh what happened in
new york
my mother said kick at the house so we
had to vote for hillary clinton
why why because i don't want to get
kicked out of the house donald trump you
know what a lot of people might think
he's racist and all that but
he's our president we love him he's
bringing money
and he's going to keep us with our guns
so we love you dearly trump
who did he vote for me i voted for
clinton to be honest because even though
trump is helping the
country he's only helping you know a
part of the country not everybody
how do you feel now and the way you've
seen it play out the way i see it play
out is
you know i'm still going to make my
money i'm still going to do me even if
it's trump or clan
i voted to claim to help you know the
poor people because they need money they
need food but
make money i feel like that he's going
to do a great job in office because he's
one he's a great businessman and
for one of him being a great businessman
you gotta you gotta have order and stuff
so i feel like he can get this country
in order because obviously it hasn't
been
ordered the way it should be tell me who
did you vape i voted for hillary
[Music]
hey the reason why the reason why i
voted for hillary
is because we don't want our country
getting messed up
we don't want it happening we want
somebody with ideals we want somebody
with ideals
the real estate mogul pushed for some
highly controversial policies
donald j trump is calling for a total
and complete shutdown
of muslims entering the united states
until our country's representatives
can figure out what the hell is going on
[Applause]
trump is right no he's not right
because he insulted all the muslims not
the bad ones he did not
insult him don't repeat it don't not
repeat it he did
no he did not well he doesn't want
anybody to come to this country to clear
problem we agree with him
we defend him we are with him it's not
because with him as a person
don't understand wrong we are with our
country even if it's democrats comments
he didn't say isis he didn't say
he said then or not this is not my
business
this is that's my business to talk about
it's whatever it's going to be
for outside this country what do you
think the next
four years looks like for muslims in
america it would be difficult here for
muslims
in america i hope it
as he i hope he will be right but
i have a feeling that you trust me it
would be difficult trust me this is the
right
44 years this is the right way and we
never treat it differently
never
[Music]
well this girl was walking to the
university camp campus
and a man came to her
and took her scarf and he said go back
to your
country she's american she born here
well so do you do you think this is
right i don't think other she's america
i don't think government can make a
decision based on one incident
this is not one accident this is one of
the many
we have are you ready for this folks are
you ready
oh they're gonna make it such a big deal
they're gonna make it so big
he said something so politically
incorrect that's why we're going to hell
because we're so politically incorrect
such a big deal such a big deal
i want surveillance of certain mosques
okay
if that's okay i want surveillance
a candidate who drew big crowds now
faces the complexities of the
constitution
once you start making that distinction
once you start saying certain people
have to
be tracked by the government uh you're
not that far
from you know first you have
registration then you have surveillance
the threat's not subtle the threat is to
create a group of disfavored
second-class citizens
[Music]
but will he be willing to shift they're
talking about a fence
in the republican congress we will build
a great wall
along the southern border we are going
to build
a great border wall we're going to build
the wall we have no choice an
impenetrable physical tall
powerful beautiful southern border
wall would you accept the fence for
certain areas i would
are you going to ask for a special
prosecutor
to investigate hillary clinton over her
emails
i am going to instruct my attorney
general
to get a special prosecutor to look into
your situation
tell hillary i'm not going to be nice
anymore i've been very nice to him
well i'll tell you what i'm going to do
i'm going to think about it special
prosecutor
i don't want to hurt them i don't want
to hurt them
they're good people
let me ask you about um obamacare
which you say you're going to repeal and
replace
real change begins with immediately
repealing and replacing obamacare a
disaster
are you going to make sure that people
with preconditions
are still coming yes because it happens
to be one of the strongest assets you're
going to keep that also with the
children living with their parents for
an extended period we're going to
you're going to very much
but you know he's been very very quiet
it's that's been the most remarkable
thing to me that he hasn't been
uh you know literally going down to the
white house to measure the drapes right
i'm kind of shocked that he hasn't done
that yet right so
donald trump has never been elected to
any office before
this is a new thing for him
one thing that is interesting to me
about what he's done so far is he's made
very few public statements
this is someone who loves to be seen
loves to be in front of an audience
loves to be on television
loves to speak his mind on twitter and
he's been relatively restrained
thanks everybody thanks everybody thank
you
tell me when you're ready
[Music]
ready okay well i just had uh the
opportunity to have an excellent
conversation with president-elect trump
it was wide-ranging we talked about
some of the organizational issues in
setting up a white house
we talked about foreign policy we talked
about domestic policy
and as i said last night my number one
priority
in the coming two months is to
try to facilitate a transition that
ensures our president-elect is
successful
i believe that it is important for all
of us
regardless of party uh and regardless of
political preferences
uh to now come together work together
to deal with uh the many challenges that
we face
you know if you saw him when he had that
meeting with president obama it's
probably the realest his face has ever
been
you know he looked like he was shook
because he probably was like
obama probably told him some stuff that
he was going to have to deal with that
we don't know about
um or just sort of really pressed upon
him the gravity of the situation and the
enormity of his job
[Music]
well thank you very much president obama
this was a meeting that was going to
last for maybe 10
or 15 minutes and we were just gonna get
to know each other we had never met each
other
uh i have great respect the meeting
lasted for almost an hour and a half
and it could have as far as i'm
concerned it could have gone on for a
lot longer
he's explained some of the difficulties
some of the the high-flying assets and
some of the
some of the really great things that
have been achieved so
mr president it was a great honor being
with you and i look forward to being
with you many many
more times in the future thank you so
much
thank you everybody we're not we are not
going to be
taking any questions thank you guys
thank you
here's a good rule don't answer your
questions when they just start
it's always the last one come on guys mr
trump will seek us out come on guys
let's go very good man thank you very
good man appreciate you
thank you guys
away from the handshakes he's blazing a
trail
speaking to some world leaders without
consulting the state department
and having a phone call with russia's
strongman
it's one of the few things trump's been
consistent on actually
is this love for putin and we've seen
you know the he
he's had a conversation with putin one
of the first calls that he made upon
becoming president-elect
his uh pick for national security
adviser
general flynn is someone who has been
close to putin and close to the russian
government
trump said during the campaign uh that
he did not have a problem with russia
being in the ukraine
going to putin first was a huge i think
signal to the rest of the world like
he's going to play nice with
vladimir putin he's going to try to have
a good relationship with russia which is
a just dramatic break with not only
democratic policies but dub republican
policies too
my opinion is
[Music]
bethel baptist church in detroit they're
praying for guidance
[Music]
our president and our president to be we
pray oh god that you would
help us to live out our faith in such a
way that regardless who's
in the white house we can always be true
to your house
in september donald trump attended
another church in the city
trying to reach out to african-american
voters
pastor lawrence glass was part of a
group of faith leaders
who objected lots of hate
actions have already been reported of
individuals who
try to intimidate other americans and
fail to realize that before we were
republicans or democrats we're americans
and we're in this thing together
and that if you if you destroy the ship
you drown too
look how much african-american
communities have suffered
under democratic control to those i
say the following
what do you have to lose
by trying something new like
trump what do you have to leave
voting rights human rights
civil rights you know for him when he
said that
that was a statement out of ignorance
and arrogance
[Music]
he needs to get in with some of the
minority groups and really go through
their neighborhood he needed to go sit
down and have lunch with him
he needed to go to the coffee shop
perhaps like barack did like president
obama did
and show that he's not afraid of them
i say it again what do you have to lose
look what do you have to lose
you're living in poverty your schools
are no good
you have no jobs
elections are popularity contests
one who win don't mean they're right the
one who lose don't mean they're
wrong doesn't mean that the masters have
[Applause]
spoken
it's always been a time for america to
heal we've been going through this
forever so this is nothing new for me
we've struggled through it all we do is
believe in god to take us through it and
we will
you've been through a tunnel before you
know how dark it is
but it's right at the end that's it
that's why that's what we are going
through right now
hopefully donald trump will um try to
work with us as the millennials and try
to
uh meet us in the middle and hopefully
my friends that are protesting in these
major cities will uh
try to meet him in the middle too
jedidiah brown was pulled from the stage
after his protest at a trump rally in
chicago in march
i ran to uh the the podium i jumped
over the barricade ran to the podium
but i was basically trying to tell the
crowd america is already great
without hatred
[Music]
i was looking at what i what i felt like
was a sea of people
who hated me for no reason they didn't
know me and it was based on things and
rhetoric in the campaign
a recent standoff in the city between
african-american activists and people
supporting the police
has put race relations back in the
spotlight
um it was something that i never thought
that i would experience in in my
lifetime
it felt like the 60s 1960s
[Music]
we were surrounded by a sea of uh
caucasian americans
telling us to go back to our uh to our
side of town
telling us that they will lynch us uh
carrying trump signs and saying trump is
gonna
you know make america great again it's
gonna build the wall this is what you
meant when you said make america great
again
this is not great this isn't great
and you know i've never seen such
volatile volatile
um hatred and expression
it just was unbelievable and i was more
in shock
than i could be in fear but there's
tension on both sides
this video shows a man who says he was
beaten after a car accident
as bystanders shouted don't vote trump
that was a gentleman there was a car
accident i believe that the gentleman
had a trump
sticker on his vehicle and he was very
brutally beaten
by uh four to five unknown
african-americans
don't vote don't vote
and you know he was about 50 years old
he was being beaten very bad
so race relations in chicago alone has
gotten extremely
intolerant and it's terrible but
jedidiah is now
ready to compromise i'm going to reach
out
i'm going to try to work with our
president what do you want to tell him
he's going to have to have people at the
table who don't see the world through
his views
and he's going to have to have people at
the table who understand
the areas that he say he wants effect
change in i'm going to tell him that if
he's
that president that he says he is then
i'm willing to be the citizen
a citizen that puts my differences down
and work with him to make america
great again
no i'm sorry i had to run off on that
one
oh my god it's the reality i think is
starting to hit me during this interview
too the road ahead will be long
our climb will be steep we may not get
there in one year or even in one term
donald trump like barack obama eight
years ago
was propelled to victory by people
looking for
change president obama was elected the
night he was elected
i climbed on top of the sink stood on
top of the sink and began to sing
old say can you see our national anthem
it was the first time in my life i felt
that i could sing it and really believe
it
and feel it like i was a part of a
country that really meant something to
me and i'm
and i meant something to my country it
is my high honor
and distinct privilege to introduce to
you the president-elect
of the united states of america donald
trump
when donald trump was elected i wanted
to climb under the sink
because i was like wow you talk about
devaluing
the history and the participation that
african-americans talk about devaluing
it and minimizing it
that that was what that election said to
me
i'm reaching out to you for your
guidance and your help
so that we can work together and unify
our great country
he thanked me he thanked me and it was
that simple
and i said now mr trump now the work
begins
and i'm very very proud to have
supported you and i had to fight back a
little bit of emotion
and it's truly been it's been one of the
greatest opportunities of my entire life
i will be president for all americans
and this is so
important to me but before the business
of government
there are fundamental riffs to repair
and no easy answers there's not a lot of
tolerance
for different points of view right now
in this country
i don't know how that's going to change
i'm going to make america better by
being a nice person by not protesting
and looting he's our servant he is to
carry out the wishes of the people
not to carry out the dreams of his
family
do we have challenges absolutely are
there some changes that need to happen
yes probably if you think that it's
great that may be all that you need
what makes america great is that we all
stand together as one because we are one
amazing beautiful country we're going to
get to work immediately for the american
people
i don't know that we can heal in this
country to be honest with you you know
we're still dealing with the civil war
in the united states i mean that's the
fact
right we can't get over that i'm not
sure that we can get over donald trump
we're going to be doing a job that
hopefully
you'll be so proud of your president
you'll be so proud
and the words of martin luther king jr
we better learn how to live together as
brothers or we're gonna die together
with food
it's been an amazing two-year period and
i love this country
thank you thank you very much